ومن الاحساء ينضم الينا مراسل صباح
العربيه عبد الرحمن العصيمي عبد الرحمن
يسعد صباحك اهلا بك المدرسه الاميريه
ايقونه التعليم والشاهد على الانطلاقه
الاولى لمسيره والتاريخ التعليم في
المملكه العربيه السعوديه
وتشوقون لهذه الجوله معك تفضل
اهلا سهام بس بدايه سهام انت كيف كنت
شاطره في المدرسه ولا كنتي مجتهده الاولى
في المدرسه عبد الرحمن
في الابتدائي كنت ممتاز في الاعدادي
والثانوي انا يعني بعدين بالجامعه استعدت
عافيتي بعض الشيء لكن هذه المدرسه سهام
يعني انا رجعتني ودخلتني حاله نفسيه عجيبه
همم الفصول
والصفحات والايام خاصه ايام البرد والشتاء
يعني كنا شوي نكره هالمدرسه اكثر لكن هذه
المدرسه العريقه جدا والتي همم اخرجت
العديد من الاسماء والشخصيات السياسيه
ياخذ لكم بعض التفاصيل وناخذ هذه الجوله
طبعا هذه المدرسه سهام كمان نشاهد تصميمها
هو مستوحها من تاريخ المنطقه ابواب خشبيه
حتى السقف كمان نشاهد هذه الاخشاب
الموجوده في السقف هي اخشاب منذ تاسيس هذه
المدرسه لم تماس ولم تغير عمرها تقريبا 90
همم سنه ايضا نشاهد هذه قاعه تدريبيه همم
المدرسه طبعا تم الاستفاده من المدرسه
وتحويلها الى مزار سياحي وايضا الاستفاده
من مرافقها بالنسبه لسكان الاحساء واهالي
المحافظه هذه المدرسه الان تحت اشراف هيئه
التراث التابعه لوزاره الثقافه الان
يقومون بعمليات ترميم وتجهيز لاستقبال همم
الاف من مشجعين كاس العالم الذين سيقدمون
من قطر التي تبعد تقريبا 200 كيلو همم من
الحساء الان هننزل للدور الثاني ان شاء
الله بس المصور همم
المدرسه هذه ايضا نعم نعم طلاب دفعتها
الاولى كانوا 70 طالب فقط حسب ما عم بشوف
الصور المدرسه واسعه كبيره
صحيح
بالضبط لانه سهام تخيلي اول مدير مدرسه
للمدرسه الاميريه في الحسا ارسل خطاب
ورساله لكل اهالي الاحساء خطاب باليد انه
يا اهل الاحساء دعوا اولادكم يتعلمون
التعليم مهم التدريس مهم ااه كان هناك
صعوبه في استقطاب الطلاب كما نشاهد الان
هذه الصوره هي الصوره لاحد الفصول عام
1947 مشاهده الطلاب عندهم قليل سهام يمكن
تقريبا حوالي 12 طالب ايضا هنا صوره اخرى
لاحد المعلمين وهو يشرح على السبوره
للطلاب فكانت البدايات البدايات التعليم
في السعوديه كانت قليله وعلى استحياء
الاساسيه في الاحساء لكن الان تخيل يا
سهام السعوديه السنويا تخرج 100,000 طالب
من ارقى جامعات العالم من المبتعثين الى
جانب طبعا في كل قريه وفي كل هجره وفي كل
بلده يوجد اكثر من المدرسه على كافه
المراحل التعليميه طبعا الان نحن في الدور
الارضي للمدرسه وهذا العام الرئيس المدرسه
ايضا الباب سهام لم يمس هو من الخشب
القديم عمره في وقت تقريبا 90 سنه تفضل
المدرسه تتميز كمان نلاحظ بتصميم ترافي
فريده تحولت لمزار سياحي هل هي مزار سياحي
فقط اليوم
هي مزار سياحي هي مكان للاستفاده من
المرافق الموجوده فيها هي ايضا معلم مهم
للاحساء طبعا هي في قلب الهفوف القديمه
بالقرب من هنا السوق اللي خرجنا منه قبل
يومين القيصريه ايضا اغلب المواقع
التراثيه قريبه من هنا لان الحساء قديما
الهفوف تحديدا اللي هي قلب الاحساء هذه هي
كانت تقريبا يمكن ثلاثه كيلو في ثلاثه
كيلو فقط همم ولكن الجميل انه هيئه التراث
مهتمه جدا بهذه المواقع والان في عمليات
ترميم وتجهيز والاستقبال المشجعين همم
مشجعين كاس العالم ان شاء الله خلال خمس
اربعه ايام ستكون كل المواقع جاهزه هي
الان مفتوحه تستقبل الزوار لكن ستكون
جاهزه اكثر فاكثر ويتم ايضا همم اعطاء بعض
الاضافات المهمه من المعلومات والصور
والارشادات لاستقبال السياح
عبد الرحمن مبهر دائما بتغطياتك الميدانيه
شكرا جزيلا عبد الرحمن من الاحسان